que hacía de charly world un músico tan
particular tan único y tan especial
buenas noches santiago y charly words
más deja de ser el baterista de los
rollitos y ser
miembro que nunca se perdió un show
era una persona de un carácter muy
discreto frente a una banda que no era
nada discreta era el hombre que los
mantenía unidos al ritmo lo mantenido en
la tierra y los mantener también unidos
como banda era un poco como el líder
silencioso que sin hablarse así escuchar
sergio cuál será el gran aporte que deja
entonces bots para la historia haciendo
los stones un grupo de rock y siendo
what's un fanático y seguidor del jazz
dos mundos completamente distintos pero
él logró acoplarse engranarse con esta
banda y llegar al éxito mundial
es que hay un secreto que no mucha gente
llega a comprender que es que el swing
del jazz de haber estudiado de ellas le
aporta mucho al rock y que rock tiene
algo de jazz en su adn
charlie watts sabía cómo activar eso y
sabía también cómo tirar un poco el
ritmo hacia atrás y con eso lograba
cierta dinámica
rítmica que es característica de los
rones todos los rollitos
tenían un baterista que era bastante
escueto como persona pero también
tocando y con menos hacia más
sergio a lo largo de esta historia los
rolling stones han escrito grandes
páginas de la historia a nivel mundial
en términos musicales que anécdotas hay
que se conoce públicamente de esa
relación que había entre watts y el
resto de integrantes de la banda y
anécdotas durante sus largas y extensas
giras alrededor del mundo
bueno al igual que no era un
protagonista de las anécdotas la
anécdota más conocida es cuando una
noche mi hija ayer me llamó borracho a
su habitación y dijo quiero ver a mi
baterista y que charlie watts se vistió
se puso el traje la corbata golpeó la
puerta de su habitación le encajó un
golpe de puño y le dijo yo no soy tu
baterista vos sos mi cantante es la más
conocida de todas pero charlie watts era
diseñador gráfico y se ocupaba mucho de
la parte estética visual de cómo era la
puesta del archivo de los rolling stones
junto con ya ayer entró entre los dos
hacían esa tarea ya haber paralizado a
otras cosas y quién richard ha estado
más ocupado en la música esto sin duda
alguna y rápidamente le preguntó va a
cambiar lo que sigue para el futuro de
los rolling stones que podemos esperar
absolutamente va a cambiar muchísimo
sobre todo para que richard que fue el
que dijo que si sale un día decía que no
quería seguir tocando la banda se
terminaba yo creo que se van a
recomponer de alguna manera con steve
jordan en la batería tiene una garantía
de buen ritmo para tener una
espectacular va a hacer reír migas
solamente que no va a ser la original
entonces creo que los rolling stones
terminada esta gira completará de un
disco y si la salud les
acompaña podrán hacer una gira de
especialidad pero todo esto en el que
estamos en el terreno de ciencia ficción